إحصائية جديدة صادمة من
المسؤولين الفلسطينيين، قُتل ما يقرب من واحد من كل
مائة شخص في غزة
منذ هجمات حماس في
السابع من أكتوبر، العاهل الأردني الملك عبد الله يقول إن الحرب
تخلق جيلًا كاملاً
من الأيتام، كما أن العنف المستمر يجعل
المرافق الطبية فاعلة مثل
مستشفى ألاكسا.  أو الأكثر أهمية
ونريد أن نحذرك بشأن الصور التي نحن على
وشك أن نظهرها لك، فهي
مزعجة بالفعل، الصور الأخيرة من
المستشفى تظهر لنا ما كنا
نتعامل معه وما يتعامل
معه الأشخاص الذين كانوا يتعاملون مع العديد من المرضى
يتم علاجهم على الأرض ولجعل
الأمور أكثر خطورة، تقول
مجموعتان على الأقل تساعدان في تقديم الرعاية في ذلك
المستشفى إنه ليس لديهم خيار سوى
الانسحاب في ضوء
النشاط العسكري الإسرائيلي المتزايد. نيك مانارد هو
جراح كان قائدًا
سريريًا  قائد فريق الطوارئ الطبي الذي
كان يعمل في المستشفى خلال
الأسبوعين الماضيين، لقد غادر للتو غزة اليوم
وينضم إلينا من القاهرة، دكتور، شكرًا
جزيلاً لك على الوقت الذي أمضيته في
التحدث إلينا، لقد كنت تعمل هناك
في علاء لمدة أسبوعين  قلنا أن
قرار المغادرة هذا لا أستطيع أن أتخيل أنه
كان قرارًا سهلاً، اشرح لمشاهدينا
سبب اضطرارك
للمغادرة أه لذلك علينا أن نحصل على اتفاق
كل يوم من قوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية
بأنه سيتم عدم النزاع للسماح لنا
بالرحيل  إلى المستشفى وكنا
نذهب إلى هناك يوميًا لمدة أسبوعين
كنا هناك يوم الجمعة كنت
أعمل طوال اليوم وأنا جراح وكان هناك
هجوم على
وحدة العناية المركزة وكان من المقرر أن نغادر في
حوالي الساعة  في ذلك الوقت على أي حال، ولكن في
صباح اليوم التالي تم إخراج المنطقة بأكملها من منطقة
خفض الاشتباك وأخبرتنا
قوات الدفاع الإسرائيلية أننا
لن نتمكن من الذهاب لذلك غادرنا. كنت
هناك مع منظمة تدعى
المساعدة الطبية للفلسطينيين ومنظمة أطباء بلا حدود.  هناك
أيضًا، واضطر جميع
الأطباء الأجانب إلى تركك
بشكل أساسي من أجل سلامتك لأنه من
الواضح أن التهديد بالهجوم، لذلك عندما
تسمع جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي يقول إنهم لا يستهدفون
المستشفيات، ماذا تقول لذلك
حسنًا، هذا ببساطة غير صحيح  أه أنا
أذهب إلى غزة منذ ما
يقرب من 15 عامًا تقريبًا ولدي العديد من الأصدقاء
الذين يعملون في المستشفيات هناك
وهناك العديد من الأمثلة على المستشفيات التي تعرضت
للهجوم في اليومين الماضيين منذ أن
غادرت مستشفى ألاكسا، كانت هناك
هجمات  على المستشفى، لذلك
ليس من المؤكد على الإطلاق أنهم لا
يهاجمون المستشفيات، هل لديك إحساس
بعدد الموظفين الذين غادروا أو
سيغادرون alexa والأثر
الحاسم هنا الذي سيحدثه هذا
على أولئك الذين يائسين  بالطبع
نحتاج إلى جراحة ودعم طبي
هنا، لذلك كنا هناك خلال اليومين أو الثلاثة أيام الماضية
حتى يوم الجمعة، كانوا
يستقبلون عدة مئات من المرضى
يوميًا، وكان هناك طبيب محلي واحد في
قسم الطوارئ، وكان
يكمله شخصان من الفريق.
كنت في قسم الجراحة في
أحد أيام الأسبوع الماضي، كان هناك
جراح محلي واحد واثنان منا،
وسمعنا لاحقًا أن غالبية
هؤلاء قد رحلوا، لذلك أخشى أنه
لا يوجد عدد كافٍ من الموظفين لإدارة المستشفى
بأي شكل على الإطلاق الآن